it's an honor to be recognized by the
academy
and to spend this fantastic week with
all the other student academy award
winners
you've given us an unforgettable and
educational expense inspiring experience
plus friendships which will hopefully
last a long time and lead to
collaborations between us
thanks to everyone at the academy
especially to sean and to tracy
i could not have made my film without
the support of stanford's mfa and
documentary film and video program
especially my professors and advisors
jan krawitz jamie meltzer
johnny simons and chris samuelson and
our technical support staff mark urbanic
and christian gainsley
and to my six classmates especially
seamus hart who did
additional cinematography and sound on
my film and helped to keep the vibe on
productions both productive and fun
i also want to extend profound thanks to
the cold cord family
the main subjects of my film don the
protagonist wanted to be here tonight
but he is the star of his town play
which also opens tonight
in his place are his wife kretha and his
grandson
gavin i'm really grateful that you made
the trek to be here thank you very much
thank you for trusting me with your
story it took a lot of courage and i'm
grateful that you did so i think we've
touched a lot of people
i also want to thank my parents
the best parts of me and my work come
from you you inspire me with your
curiosity
your intellect and your kindness i'm
grateful to be a sheer
and i'm also grateful to be here thank
you very much